وزير الزراعه الاوكراني النفاثه وجود اي
انباء عن تعليق تصدير الحبوب من موانئ
وديسا بعد الهجمات الروسيه ومن المقرر ان
يجري الرئيس التركي اتصالين هاتفيين اليوم
مع نظيره
الاوكراني لمناقشه تعزيز اتفاق الممر
الامن للحبوب وذلك عبر البحر الاسود
التي تنص على توريد المنتجات الزراعيه
الروسيه للاسواق العالميه الى جانب الحبوب
من الموانئ الاخرانيه
الروسيه في بياننا الا ان التنفيذ النزيه
لاتفاق الحبوب سيساهم في ضمان امن الغذاء
العالمي و يساهم ايضا في مساعده الدول
المحتاجه في افريقيا اسيا وامريكا
اللاتينيه
في بيانها انه تم الى واهتمام خاص خلال
المشاورات لتطورات الوضع في اوكرانيا وان
الجانب الروسيه اطلع تركيا على سير
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
وعلى استمرار القوات الاوكرانيه باستهدف
المدنيين والبنيه التحتيه المدنيه في
دمباس وخير جورجيا بحسب وصف البيان الروسي